Libertarians take a dark View at
anti-discrimination laws and public
accommodation laws that say if you open
your business to the public you've got
to serve everybody does this case
fundamentally challenge or engage that
kind of issue
brush has passed it and I'll say by way
of uh background that exactly half the
states currently have public
accommodation laws in which sexual
orientation or gender identity are one
of the productive categories so by that
definition half of America was already a
hellscape i
will go along with your term for good
people or also or else you may not
notice it because in fact in those other
25 States it's very hard to find any
actual instances in which other than
with wedding services and a couple of
very narrowly defined controversies very
difficult to find any difference in in
treatment
um
Libertarians
um uh you're right you're absolutely
right uh have a uh
um I think Justified suspicion of the
attempt to use public accommodation laws
to
override the independent Judgment of
businesses of how to serve and I say
brushed against it because both the
majority and the minority in the 303
creative case
uh did turn to history
um there were questions uh
um which may shed light on whether
public accommodation laws were a fairly
rare and exceptional thing or were
something that were completely accepted
even in the grand old libertarian
classical liberal period uh it was
certainly accepted that some businesses
like
uh ends to stay the night in a country
where you might freeze to death if they
wouldn't take you in were under a public
accommodation obligation we do know that
about anglo-american history
um and some others
um uh closely related in the hospitality
business uh what about someone who would
fix your shoes what about someone who
would bake you a kick well
the majority brushes by theory that
if you look at old instances where
classical liberal societies accepted the
public accommodation
um idea the idea that businesses on
undertook a particular accommodation
that it uh aside from the hospitality on
the road cases they were very often
Monopoly cases if you're going to give a
company a monopoly over something you
darn well are going to give them an
obligation to serve every single
customer
um and then the dissent by Sotomayor
said oh no no by the time she was done
talking about it you would really would
think that every single person who ever
offered any services or products was
under Republic accommodations obligation
which I think is not actually true if
you go back to the to the old law books
so so they both found it worth engaging
and yet on one level it what they said
does not change uh The Sweep of these
laws it doesn't give me the opportunity
to say as a Libertarian that the stakes
of social division go down if you don't
Define every through single florist and
calligrapher as a public accommodation
if you take a reasonable view that you
know some things are big and public
enough like theaters that uh there is
some sort of public stigma in not being
allowed but if you try to extend it to
every little uh one person business you
are going to have more social division
you just are can I ask Wally as as a gay
man who I believe is married correct uh
well Steve I think so okay yeah
um
um maybe married in multiple States I
don't know you know it's like uh but you
know how when you read about somebody
who is like you know what like I'll make
you a website but like I'll be damned if
I'm gonna you know write you know you
know here's our gift registry for a
wedding or all you can buy a cake I
baked but I'll be damned if I'm gonna
write you know best wishes you know
except I mean like how you know how did
you respond to that on an individual
visual level well I there's a great line
from uh Zora Neil Hurston about uh being
discriminated against you I can't
imagine she said why people would want
to deprive themselves of the Delight of
my company
that is a confident person's uh response
to being distributed against obviously
she lived in bad circumstances in the
South and she knew perfectly well that
there was more and worse to be out of
discrimination but I love the attitude
because especially when the
Discrimination is just symbolic and is
not actually causing you to uh not be
able to get the the job or the home or
whatever uh you just brush it off as
people who haven't learned what they
need to know about the world uh it's um
um and and here we got to the series of
cases involving masterpiece cake shop
and the flowers case and now the website
case which is uh it's very hard to find
any of those cases in which uh gay
people getting married uh or these date
back to the point where you couldn't get
married and it was just uh solemnizing a
a relationship very hard to find any of
these instances in which the people
didn't have lots of other good choices
of people who would gladly observed
their business and uh so again it gets
me thinking about zoria Holston oh are
you just trying to say in order to make
a point
yeah uh zornale Hurston is uh somebody
who we can all do we can all benefit
from uh you know thinking about a lot
more and looking at her life as
certainly her literary output but but
there's a real sense of tragedy there
and Coleman I know that you're familiar
with Zorn Neil Hurston who you know was
uh also a Columbia student uh back in
the day and studied with Franz Boaz and
the anthropology department and suffered
real massive indignities is that
uh you know on the account of both her
gender and her race but I mean is it
that we are in a stage now and it's
always you know uh it you know we're
always declaring Victory way too soon in
all kinds of Wars right but like is it
the world that she lived in and that
level of anger and hate and contempt for
sexual minorities for racial minorities
for ethnic minorities is that mostly
behind us and is that something that we
need to incorporate into our
contemporary discussions of things
it's interesting I'm of two minds on
this on the one hand I think we have
made massive progress in people's
attitudes towards minorities uh racial
minorities sexual minorities Etc
on the other hand I don't think that
these bigotrys will ever be gone fully
and permanently I think
um I I I think Human Nature has a
bigoted element to it that is reducible
but not eradicable
and and uh
uh at some level we're going to be
living with some amount of racism some
amount of homophobia until the end of
time and we should
while combating it we should understand
that hmm
yeah
um uh Wally can I ask from uh you know
and again this is going back into the uh
you know kind of libertarian subculture
people like Milton Friedman talked about
this as well as a wide variety of other
people whose motivations may not have
been as clear or as pure I think as
Friedman's but
um you know there is an argument and I
guess Gary Becker also made this another
Nobel Prize funding Economist saying you
know that businesses that discriminate
in a stupid and foolish way or and you
know well actually be punished by
markets operating
um so you know that that 303 creative
you know probably uh isn't that good a
website anyway or we'll lose enough
business uh you know that uh companies
that refuse to hire women or blacks or
you know Latinos who were good workers
um you know end up paying more higher
wages for shittier workers and things
like that is it is it more than
theoretical to say that you know markets
relatively free markets actually punish
discriminatory Behavior
it's a big topic Nick and I can offer
particular examples that back up uh
Milton Friedman's suggestions uh it's
well known I think that in the South
during Jim Crow uh railroads and others
who needed a lot of skilled Weber uh
were uh constantly seeing if they could
undermine uh Jim Crow because it was
denying them access to a lot of workers
who would have done very well and the um
it gets complicated because as Coleman
said sometimes you've got a background
of uh real uh social Prejudice in uh
that has not been eradicated and markets
can sometimes transmit that in that if
bigoted customers won't visit your
restaurant or whatever
um so I don't want to make sweeping
assertions I think that
um courts by and large uh decide and
should decide the cases and other bases
where these things come in again is
every one of those state and local
anti-discrimination and public
accommodations laws was passed through a
legislative process in which people
could wave some of these things and I
urge people again as someone who not not
just from my libertarian standpoint but
as someone who doesn't want to see
social divisiveness
um you know that's the time to go in and
say are you legislating just to
demonstrate your virtue or is there
riddling of some social uh problem that
is solved by extending it from
um uh old style public accommodations to
every single little one-person operation
but you would agree that public
accommodation laws which do restrict the
right of businesses to operate however
they see fit are actually beneficial in
certain cases well I I would say from a
Libertarian standpoint
um I'd I follow I think this is the
Richard Epstein analysis I'd like to uh
confine them to the cases where there is
a practical Monopoly uh ironically uh
ends to stay for the night which were
effectively uh impractical if not a
royally granted Monopoly uh centuries
ago you know with Airbnb uh it you know
not not at all but
um you know I don't mind for utilities
and I can see at least their point uh if
someone is going to freeze the doubt of
saying uh the Inn is uh freighted with a
special public interest
um but I would make it as
um I would make it ending test that
wouldn't result in very many public
accommodations laws that was an excerpt
from our reason live stream with Walter
Olson of the Cato Institute and Coleman
Hughes talking about recent Court
decisions dealing with affirmative
action and whether or not website
operators had to serve gay couples if
you want to see another excerpt go here
if you want to see the full thing and
you should go here